(man) THESE ARE THE SHARKS--
FIVE POWERFUL,
SELF-MADE INVESTORS
WORTH BILLIONS.
TONIGHT THEY WILL
MAKE OR BREAK THE DREAMS
OF HOPEFUL ENTREPRENEURS.
♪♪
IN THE TANK, THE SHARKS
ARE READY TO INVEST
USING THEIR OWN MONEY,
BUT ONLY FOR THE RIGHT PERSON
WITH THE RIGHT IDEA.
DO YOU WANT TO BE RICH
OR NOT?
I DO WANT TO BE RICH.
WELL, LET'S GET FOCUSED
ON THAT, BUDDY.
AS OF RIGHT NOW,
YOU'RE NOBODY TO EVERYBODY.
NO ONE CAN STOP ME FROM WHAT
I WANT TO ACCOMPLISH.
IN THESE TOUGH ECONOMIC TIMES,
THE SHARKS ARE THE LAST CHANCE
FOR MANY ENTREPRENEURS
TO GET THE FINANCIAL BACKING
THEY DESPERATELY NEED.
IT WAS ALWAYS EMOTIONAL
FOR ME.
MONEY HAS NO SOUL.
IT DOESN'T CARE.
I'LL MAKE YOU A BETTER OFFER.
I'LL GIVE YOU $1 MILLION.
(blows air)
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
KEVIN O'LEARY
KNOWS HOW TO MAKE MONEY.
HE STARTED A SOFTWARE BUSINESS
IN HIS BASEMENT,
WHICH HE EVENTUALLY SOLD
FOR $3.2 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN--
THIS FIERY REAL ESTATE MOGUL
TURNED A $1,000 LOAN
INTO A REAL ESTATE EMPIRE
WORTH HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
IN THE SHARK-FILLED CITY
OF MANHATTAN.
KEVIN HARRINGTON
IS THE KING OF INFOMERCIALS.
HIS GENIUS MARKETING
OF PRODUCTS
SUCH AS THE OBAMA COIN
AND THE ROCK 'N ROLL STEPPER
HAS AMASSED
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN SALES.
DAYMOND JOHN LITERALLY TURNED
RAGS TO RICHES
WITH HIS CLOTHING BRAND FUBU,
WHICH HAS GROSSED OVER
$6 BILLION
IN WORLDWIDE RETAIL SALES
TO DATE.
AND ROBERT HERJAVEC, WHO SOLD
HIS INTERNET COMPANIES
FOR OVER $350 MILLION.
NOW THIS SELF-MADE
TECHNOLOGY MAGNATE
IS A VENTURE CAPITALIST
AND RUNS
HIS OWN SOFTWARE COMPANY.
IF THE SHARKS HEAR A GOOD IDEA,
THEY'LL FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A PIECE OF IT.
ROBERT JUST OFFERED YOU NOTHING
AND TOLD YOU TO POUND SAND.
NO, I DIDN'T.
I DIDN'T DO THAT.
I GAVE HIM A SHOT AT THE BRASS
RING. YOU'RE GIVING HIM NOTHING.
YOU'VE JUST SEEN A GUY
SCREW HIS PARTNERS.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
BUT FIRST THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST CONVINCE THE SHARKS
TO INVEST THE FULL AMOUNT
THEIR ASKING FOR
OR THEY'LL WALK AWAY
WITH NOTHING.
WHAT WOULD I PAY FOR THAT?
UH, $9.50.
(Daymond) $9.50 FOR ONE?
STOP THE MADNESS.
ARE YOU OUT OF YOUR MIND?
YES.
OUCH.
I'M OUT.
I'M OUT ALSO.
HE'S OUT, I'M OUT.
(man) ♪ THE BEST THINGS
IN LIFE ARE FREE ♪
♪ BUT THAT AIN'T REALLY
GOOD ENOUGH FOR ME ♪
♪ I NEED MONEY ♪
♪ THAT'S WHAT I WANT ♪
♪ WHAT I WANT ♪
FIRST INTO THE SHARK TANK
IS CRAIG FRENCH,
WHO BELIEVES HIS BUSINESS
COULD BE THE NEXT BIG THING
IN FASHION.
♪♪
MY NAME IS CRAIG FRENCH
FROM LONG ISLAND, NEW YORK.
MY PARTNER DENIZ AND I
CAME UP WITH A CLOTHING COMPANY
CALLED CROOKED JAW.
I CAME UP WITH THE NAME
AFTER BREAKING MY JAW
PLAYING COLLEGE LACROSSE.
WE STARTED OFF JUST PRODUCING
A COUPLE OF T-SHIRTS,
AND IMMEDIATELY, WE GOT
RESPONSE FROM PEOPLE.
SOME HAPPY CUSTOMERS,
THEY'LL BE GETTING THIS PACKAGE
IN A COUPLE OF DAYS.
(man) HEY, CRAIG. HOW ARE YOU?
I JUST WANTED TO COME IN
AND SHOW YOU
A COUPLE NEW DESIGNS WE GOT.
I KNOW WE DID WELL WITH THEM
IN THE LAST COLOR,
SO WE FIGURED WE'D DO 'EM--
OH, THIS IS NICE. THIS IS SWEET.
THIS WILL SELL REALLY WELL.
COOL.
I THINK WHAT THE SHARKS
CAN BRING TO OUR BUSINESS
IS ENORMOUS.
THIS ONE STORE
IS NOT GONNA PAY THE BILLS,
THAT'S FOR SURE.
THEIR EXPERIENCE
IN THE BUSINESS WORLD,
THEIR CONNECTIONS,
THE NETWORKING THEY COULD DO
FOR US IS IMMENSE,
BUT IN PARTICULAR, DAYMOND JOHN.
DAYMOND JOHN IS THE FOUNDER
OF FUBU CLOTHING.
STARTED OFF IN HIS MOTHER'S
HOUSE, SIMILAR TO MYSELF.
AND IT SLOWLY TURNED INTO
A MULTIMILLION-DOLLAR
CLOTHING BUSINESS.
I'M 26 YEARS OLD
AND STILL LIVING AT HOME.
AS ALL MY FRIENDS
ARE OUT PARTYING,
YOU KNOW,
LIVING THE BACHELOR LIFE,
I'M HOME LIVING WITH MY MOTHER
JUST TO KEEP MY BUSINESS AFLOAT.
CRAIG, YOU HAVE TO EAT.
OKAY, HON?
MY MOTHER HAS BEEN THERE FOR ME
FROM THE GET-GO.
SHE'S BEEN AMAZINGLY SUPPORTIVE.
IT WOULD MEAN THE WORLD TO ME
TO BE ABLE TO GIVE BACK TO HER
EVERYTHING SHE'S GIVEN TO ME.
♪♪
HELLO, GUYS.
MY NAME IS CRAIG FRENCH.
I AM HERE
WITH MY CLOTHING COMPANY
CALLED CROOKED JAW.
WE ARE SEEKING
A $200,000 INVESTMENT
FOR 20% EQUITY
OF THE COMPANY.
WE ARE TARGETING A MARKET
THAT IS BOOMING RIGHT NOW--
THE M.M.A.--
MIXED MARTIAL ARTS INDUSTRY.
IT'S HUGE RIGHT NOW WITH
THE YOUNG KIDS, AND WE BELIEVE
THAT WE COULD BE THE NEXT
BIG BRAND IN THE INDUSTRY.
HAVE YOU SOLD ANY PRODUCT YET?
WE HAVE SOLD
ABOUT 1,500 UNITS.
WE'RE IN ABOUT TEN
MOM-AND-POP
SURF-AND-SKATE SHOPS
ON LONG ISLAND.
WE JUST OPENED UP, UH,
OUR OWN ONLINE RETAIL SHOP
ABOUT THREE WEEKS AGO.
WHAT'S ON THE T-SHIRT THERE,
THE RED ONE?
CAN I SEE A DESIGN JUST TO GET
AN IDEA OF THE FLAVOR OF IT?
ABSOLUTELY.
THAT'S A NASTY LOOKING CLOWN.
SHOW EVERYBODY.
CRAIG, HOW DID YOU
COME UP WITH THIS?
WERE YOU A DESIGNER GUY?
I GOT MY JAW BROKEN.
UH, FRESHMAN YEAR OF COLLEGE,
I WAS PLAYING LACROSSE,
AND I SHOT AND SCORED
THE GAME-WINNING GOAL.
EVERYONE CELEBRATES.
I GOT HIT AT THE SAME EXACT TIME
AS I--AS I SCORED THE GOAL.
I'VE HAD EXTENSIVE ORAL SURGERY
ON MY FACE,
HAD TO CUT OFF MY EAR,
GO INTO MY HEAD.
WOW. YOU REALLY GOT HIT.
OH, YEAH. IT WAS ALWAYS
EMOTIONAL FOR ME.
ARE THESE YOUR PARTNERS?
THESE ARE MY TWO PARTNERS
RIGHT HERE.
AND THIS IS
OUR BEAUTIFUL MODEL.
SO IT'S A GREAT STORY.
THANK YOU.
LOVE THE T-SHIRT.
I'M GONNA BUY THAT.
WOULD YOU GIVE ME
THAT T-SHIRT FOR FREE?
YOU COULD HAVE IT, YES.
ALL RIGHT. DAYMOND, HOW MANY
GUYS LIKE THAT ARE OUT THERE?
THERE ARE A THOUSAND GUYS
LIKE THIS.
OUCH.
AND IF HE'S ONLY
IN STORES IN LONG ISLAND,
THAT MEANS HE NEVER WENT
TO A TRADE SHOW--
YEAH, WE WENT
TO OUR FIRST TRADE SHOW
ABOUT THREE MONTHS AGO
IN SAN DIEGO.
DO YOU HAVE ORDERS?
UM, NO. WE CAME BACK WITH
ZERO ORDERS FROM THE TRADE SHOW.
BUT WE MADE
AMAZING CONTACTS AT--
DAYMOND, ISN'T THAT
A BAD SIGN--ZERO ORDERS?
WELL, IF--
I'M NOT A FASHION GUY, BUT ZERO
ORDERS DOESN'T SOUND GOOD.
IN... IT DEPENDS.
WELL, IT'S THE ECONOMY.
IT'S USUALLY HORRIFIC.
IT'S NOT BAD.
FOR RIGHT NOW,
IF THERE'S NOTHING THERE
THAT REALLY LENDS ITSELF
TO M.M.A...
WHAT ABOUT THIS?
BESIDES
THE JAW IDEA ITSELF, UM--
IS HE ONE IN A THOUSAND?
MM. 10,000, MAYBE.
IF YOU GO
TO THE TRADE SHOW,
YOU'RE GONNA SEE VARIOUS AMOUNT
OF BRANDS LIKE THIS,
SO UNLESS HE HAS
HARD PAPER IN SALES
OR SOME OF THE MOST KEY M.M.A.
GUYS WEARING THE PRODUCT--
I CAN--I COULD
GET INTO ALL THAT WITH YOU.
OBVIOUSLY WITH
THE BAD ECONOMY RIGHT NOW,
A LOT OF COMPANIES
DON'T WANT TO RISK
A BRAND-NEW STARTUP COMPANY,
BUT WE HAVE AN ONLINE RETAIL
SHOP THAT WE COULD PURSUE,
AS WELL AS EVERY MAJOR
M.M.A. EVENT,
WE GET OPPORTUNITIES TO SPONSOR
THE MOST TOP-FLIGHT ATHLETES
ON THAT CARD.
CRAIG, THEY'RE ASKING YOU
FOR MONEY.
(Daymond)
YEAH, WE ALL GET THOSE.
YEAH, I MEAN, THAT--I COULD
SPONSOR AN M.M.A EVENT.
BUT YOU HAVE TO HAVE A BRAND
THAT THE KIDS ARE GONNA LIKE
WHEN THE GUY WALKS OUT--
NO, THEY JUST WANT MY MONEY
FOR ADVERTISING.
(Daymond) THEY JUST WANT
OUR MONEY.
SO, CRAIG, I'M GONNA
SUMMARIZE IT FOR ME.
OKAY.
UM, YOU'RE NOT DOING A GOOD JOB
OF IMPRESSING DAYMOND.
SO IF--IF MR. CLOTHING GUY--
I WOULD LIKE TO SHOW DAYMOND
MY CLOTHING,
BECAUSE HE HASN'T EVEN ASKED
TO SEE IT.
SHOW ME. I-I, YOU KNOW...
DAYMOND, I-I CAME--
BECAUSE I CAME FROM WHERE YOU--
WHERE YOU CAME FROM,
SO I DO NOT WANT TO BE HARSH.
OKAY.
OH, REALLY?
I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT--
YOU ASKED ME THE QUESTION.
WHAT ARE YOU LIKE
WHEN YOU'RE HARSH?
DAYMOND, IF YOU'RE NOT
IMPRESSED WITH THIS STUFF,
THEN, YOU KNOW, I--
I REALLY LIKE THAT.
OH, THAT'S COOL.
WE HAVE OUR OWN ZIPPERS--
YOU KNOW, TO BE VERY HONEST,
GUYS AT YOUR LEVEL,
YOU EITHER HAVE TO HAVE
A TALENT ATTACHED TO THE BRAND
OR A RETAILER WHO IS GUARANTEED
TO PUT IT OUT.
WITH YOUR MONEY, DAYMOND,
I COULD GO
AND FLY TO THESE PLACES,
WE COULD HAVE SIT-DOWN MEETINGS.
THIS--THIS DAY AND AGE,
YOU MAIL THIS TO 'EM,
THEY'RE GONNA SEND YOU
THE PAPER,
THEY'RE GONNA
SEND YOU THE ORDERS,
AND THAT'S THE WAY THAT
I WOULD BACK THIS COMPANY.
WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO BUILD
THE BRAND WITH YOUR MONEY
AND MAKE THIS A BRAND
THAT THEY CAN'T RESIST.
AND I THINK WE HAVE
AN AMAZING BRAND.
WE HAVE BUILT THIS BRAND
NATIONWIDE
IN THREE YEARS
WITH VERY LITTLE MONEY--
I DO THINK THAT
YOU MAY HAVE SOMETHING--
ARE YOU LOOKING AT YOURSELF
TEN YEARS AGO?
I'M GONNA--I'M GONNA READ
YOU GUYS A LITTLE SOMETHING
I HAVE
ON ALL OF OUR HANGTAGS.
"THERE IS NO EASY WAY TO ACHIEVE
WHAT I DESIRE MOST.
"PERSEVERANCE WILL ALLOW ME
TO FULFILL MY DREAMS.
NO ONE CAN STOP ME FROM WHAT
I WANT TO ACCOMPLISH."
I WROTE THAT QUOTE.
IT'S ON EVERY HANGTAG
WE GIVE TO OUR PRODUCTS.
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
I'VE GOT SOMETHING HERE.
I'M MONEY.
I DON'T GIVE A DAMN.
I JUST WANT TO HAVE MORE MONEY.
THAT'S WHAT THIS SAYS.
ABSOLUTELY.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND
HOW TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN
WITH WHAT YOU'RE TELLING ME.
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, I'M SPEAKING
A LITTLE BIT TO DAYMOND HERE.
THERE'S A MILLION GUYS
OUT THERE LIKE ME.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S
A MILLION GUYS LIKE US
THAT HAVE THE PASSION
AND PURSUIT THAT WE HAVE
THAT COME FROM A REAL PLACE.
I'M--I'M LISTENING TO YOU,
AND IT'S VERY IMPRESSIVE.
I MEAN, I LIKE YOUR,
YOU KNOW--
I WOULD BUY INTO THE BRAND
BECAUSE OF YOU.
BUT THE BRAND ITSELF RIGHT NOW,
IT NEEDS MORE LEGS.
YOU DON'T HAVE ORDERS--
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE.
I NEED TO BUY SWEAT EQUITY THAT
YOU ALREADY HAVE PUT IN THERE.
ALL YOU'VE DONE
IS MANUFACTURED SOMETHING.
I COULD MANUFACTURE IT.
THAT'S NOT THE PROBLEM.
I NEED YOU TO HAVE A FOLLOWING.
WITH VERY LITTLE MONEY, WE'VE
CREATED AN AMAZING FOLLOWING.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
WHAT ARE OUR SALES?
THEY'RE VERY INSIGNIFICANT.
VERY INSIGNIFICANT.
LIKE WHAT? LIKE WHAT?
WHAT DID YOU SELL?
WHAT WERE YOUR SALES
LAST YEAR?
WE'VE PROBABLY SOLD
5 GRAND WORTH OF PRODUCT.
(groans)
CRAIG, YOU'RE--YOU'RE--
YOU'RE CRASHING AND BURNING.
I'M OUT.
I'M OUT, TOO.
DAYMOND, ARE YOU GONNA
INVEST IN THIS?
IF YOU'RE IN, I'M FOLLOWING,
'CAUSE YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
WHY ARE YOU MAKING IT
ALL MY, YOU KNOW--
(Robert) YOU'RE MR. CLOTHING.
YOU'RE THE CLOTHING GUY.
(Barbara) DAYMOND, COME ON.
YOU GONNA INVEST?
♪♪
WITH TWO SHARKS ALREADY OUT,
CRAIG NEEDS DAYMOND
TO TURN THE TIDE.
(Daymond) YOU KNOW,
TO BE VERY HONEST,
AS OF RIGHT NOW,
YOU'RE NOBODY TO EVERYBODY.
OKAY.
I'M--I'M...
I'M OUT.
ALL RIGHT.
HE'S OUT, I'M OUT.
FOUR SHARKS HAVE BAILED OUT.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS CRAIG'S
LAST CHANCE FOR AN INVESTMENT.
♪♪
CRAIG, YOU KNOW, LOOK,
I'M JUST AN INVESTOR TRYING TO
SCRATCH OUT A LIVING HERE, OKAY?
I'M LISTENING TO THIS.
I LOVE YOU.
I LOVE YOUR STORY--
THE BROKEN JAW,
THE G--THE WINNING GOAL,
ALL THAT STUFF--I LOVE ALL THAT.
BUT YOU GOT
A TOUGH DEAL HERE, BUDDY.
I CAN'T GIVE YOU MY MONEY
BECAUSE I DON'T SEE
HOW I'M GONNA GET IT BACK
WITH MORE OF IT THERE.
IT'S ALL ABOUT INVESTING.
I'M OUT.
BUT I WANT TO BUY
SOME OF THIS STUFF.
THAT'S HOW--HOW CONFLICTED I AM.
WHAT'S THIS THING WORTH?
I'M BUYING THIS RIGHT HERE.
HOW MUCH?
(chuckles) I DON'T WANT
TO TAKE YOUR MONEY.
YOU WON'T TAKE MY MONEY?
THAT'S OKAY.
THAT'S--
YOU CAN HAVE IT.
IT'S MY GIFT TO YOU GUYS.
THIS IS WHAT WE DO.
CRAIG, THANKS FOR YOUR TIME.
THANKS, GUYS.
(Barbara) GOOD LUCK.
(Robert) GOOD LUCK.
(O'Leary)
GOOD LUCK TO YOU.
♪♪
I LIKE THE GUY.
I LOVE THE GUY.
YOU DIDN'T LIKE THE DESIGNS?
MAN, YOU ARE ONE TOUGH GUY.
I AM NOT. THIS IS
A BLACK HOLE RIGHT HERE.
AND IF HE KEEPS SPENDING
HIS MONEY, HE'S GONNA SPEND
EVERYBODY'S MONEY,
AND HE'S GONNA BE OUT OF IT.
I'M DISAPPOINTED. I'M SAD.
BUT I BELIEVE IN WHAT I'M DOING.
I'M NOT GONNA STOP BECAUSE OF
A COUPLE OF SHARKS
WHO THINK THAT THEY KNOW
EVERYTHING ABOUT BUSINESS.
♪♪
MY NAME'S ROBERT ALLISON.
I'M THE INVENTOR OF LIFEBELT.
THIS IS MY SON MICHAEL,
AND HE'S GONNA BE
SHOWING US HOW IT WORKS.
FIRST THING I WANT YOU TO DO,
SON, IS TRY AND START THE CAR
WITHOUT PUTTING ON
YOUR SEAT BELT.
(ignition clicks, chime dings)
DID THE CAR START? OKAY.
NO.
ONCE LIFEBELT'S INSTALLED,
A VEHICLE CAN'T BE STARTED
UNTIL THE DRIVER
FASTENS THEIR SAFETY BELT.
PUT ON YOUR SEAT BELT.
GOSH.
THE NUMBER ONE CAUSE OF DEATH
AND KILLER OF TEENS
IN OUR COUNTRY, HANDS DOWN,
IS CAR CRASHES.
TRY IT NOW.
(engine turns over)
AS A PARENT, THERE'S NO WAY
I'D LET MY SON DRIVE
WITHOUT THE PROTECTION
THAT LIFEBELT OFFERS.
I BELIEVE THAT EVERY PARENT
IN THE COUNTRY
WOULD WANT ONE
FOR THEIR SONS AND DAUGHTERS
IF THEY KNEW LIFEBELT EXISTED.
♪♪
GOOD AFTERNOON,
GENTLEMEN, MA'AM.
MY NAME IS ROBERT ALLISON.
I'M THE CREATOR
OF LIFEBELT INC.
I'M HERE TODAY REQUESTING
$500,000 IN FUNDING FOR 10%.
LIFEBELT, IN SHORT,
IS A PIECE OF SAFETY EQUIPMENT
THAT PREVENTS YOU FROM
BEING ABLE TO START YOUR CAR
WITHOUT FIRST
BUCKLING YOUR SEAT BELT.
THE REASON I'VE--I'M EXCITED
ABOUT THIS OPPORTUNITY
IS THAT
IF I CAN GET MY PRODUCT
OUT IN FRONT
OF THE AMERICAN PUBLIC,
THEN POSSIBLY WE CAN HELP
TO ELIMINATE
SOME OF THE TEEN FATALITIES
THAT OCCUR EVERY YEAR.
HOW DOES IT WORK EXACTLY?
LIKE I SEE A LITTLE BLACK BOX...
THE LARGER BLACK SQUARE TAPS
INTO THE VEHICLE'S FUSE BOX.
THE PRIMARY FUNCTION
IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE DRIVER HAS ON
HIS OR HER SEAT BELT.
HOW DID YOU
COME UP WITH THIS?
ABOUT SEVEN YEARS AGO, UH,
I HAD A LOVED ONE
THAT LOST HER SISTER
TO A, UH, CAR CRASH.
THE LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH
IN OUR COUNTRY--
RESOUNDINGLY--
IS TRAFFIC CRASHES.
IF YOU HAVE ON A PROPERLY WORN
SHOULDER HARNESS,
THE CHANCES OF YOU WALKING AWAY
FROM A TRAFFIC CRASH UNINJURED
OR NOT DECEASED
GO UP BY UP TO 86%.
I LOVE THE CONCEPT, ROBERT.
WALK ME THROUGH THE--THE COSTS.
WHAT--WHAT DO YOU SELL
THE UNIT FOR?
WHAT'S IT COST
TO GET IT INSTALLED?
UH, INSTALLED, RIGHT NOW
IN LAS VEGAS,
WHICH IS WHERE I LIVE, I'VE GOT
TWO DIFFERENT SHOPS THERE
THAT DO IT FOR $229 INSTALLED.
COULD AN AVERAGE PERSON
INSTALL THIS HIMSELF OR--
YES.
'CAUSE $229 SOUNDS
A LITTLE PRICEY TO ME.
DO YOU HAVE
A PATENT FOR IT?
OF COURSE. IT'S PATENTED.
I OWN THE PATENT,
THE COPYRIGHT,
I OWN THE FCC LICENSING.
WHY NOT GO TO THE CAR COMP--
LIKE, WHY BUILD A BUSINESS?
'CAUSE IF WE GOT--IF YOU AND I
GOT ONE OF THESE
IN EVERY SINGLE CAR...
WE'D BE VERY, VERY RICH.
'CAUSE I'LL TELL YOU,
I LOVE THE IDEA.
I MEAN, I LOVE THE IDEA.
BUT I AM NEVER GONNA BUY
ONE OF THESE...
(Barbara) EXACTLY.
AND THEN TAKE IT TO A MECHANIC.
IT'S TOO MUCH HASSLE.
IF I'M A LARGE CAR MANUFACTURER,
AND I WANT TO PUT THIS IN,
DO I HAVE TO GO TO YOU
FOR THE PATENT?
YES.
SO--SO THAT'S THE BIG ELEPHANT
IN THE ROOM.
LIKE, WHY AREN'T YOU DOING THAT?
I-I HAVE SPOKEN TO ENGINEERS
AT ALL THREE OF THE MAJOR
AUTOMOBILE MANUFACTURERS
HERE IN THIS COUNTRY.
ONE IN PARTICULAR
IS EXTREMELY INTERESTED,
BUT DOES IT TAKE ANOTHER
FIVE YEARS TO GET TO THAT POINT?
(Harrington) THERE'S
TWO WAYS TO SELL IT.
ONE IS TO--AT THE POINT
OF MANUFACTURE,
THE OTHER IS AT THE TIME--
THE POINT OF SALE OF THE CAR.
THE AUTOMOTIVE
AFTERMARKET BUSINESS...
OH.
IS A HUGE BUSINESS.
THE PROBLEM IS, JUST LIKE
WHEN I JUST WALKED IN HERE,
YOU DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
THIS EXISTED.
AND SO WHEN I CALL ON
SOME OF THE BIGGER
NATIONWIDE AUTO CHAINS,
THEY'VE NEVER HEARD OF ME,
THEY'VE NEVER HEARD
OF THE PRODUCT--
BUT, ROBERT, WE KNOW THAT.
SO WHAT IF THEY'VE NEVER
HEARD OF YOU.
NOBODY EVER HEARD OF ME WHEN I
STARTED MY FIRST BUSINESS,
AND I SOLD IT FOR $100 MILLION.
ROBERT, YOU'RE NOT MAKING
ANY MONEY RIGHT NOW
DOING THIS, ARE YOU?
NO, I'M NOT, NO.
OKAY, SO LET'S--LET'S AGREE
ON ONE THING.
JUST--I WANT
TO HEAR YOU SAY THIS,
'CAUSE I'M NOT SURE
YOU'RE GOING TO.
THE ONLY THING OF VALUE HERE
IS THE PATENT, YES OR NO?
YES.
MY BIGGEST CONCERN
IS NOT SO MUCH YOUR PRODUCT,
BUT I DON'T SEE YOU
SELLING THIS THING.
SO I, FOR ONE,
ON THAT BASIS ALONE, I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
UM, YOU KNOW, THE BIGGEST
ISSUE I HAVE HERE
IS--IS THE VALUATION.
UH, $500,000 FOR 10%,
UH, IS--IS JUST--
RIGHT. THAT'S NUTS.
I-I MEAN, IT'S--
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
ON THE VALUATION BASIS,
ROBERT, I'M SORRY,
BUT I'M--I'M OUT ALSO.
UNTIL THERE IS A CAR COMPANY
LICENSING THIS THING,
THIS WILL BE AN ENDLESS
AND FRUITLESS JOURNEY
OF, UM, SPENDING MONEY.
I'M OUT.
ROBERT, I'LL MAKE YOU
AN OFFER.
I'LL BUY YOUR PATENT
FOR $500,000--
100% OF IT.
I WANT TO SEPARATE YOU
FROM THE PATENT,
AND I DON'T WANT YOU
TO CALL ME EVER AGAIN.
ROBERT, I'LL MAKE YOU
A BETTER OFFER.
I'LL GIVE YOU $1 MILLION
FOR 100% OF THE PATENT,
AND YOU CAN CALL ME ONCE.
♪♪
ROBERT, I'LL MAKE YOU
A BETTER OFFER.
I'LL GIVE YOU $1 MILLION
FOR 100% OF THE PATENT,
AND YOU CAN CALL ME ONCE.
A $1-MILLION OFFER
IS ON THE TABLE,
AND ROBERT IS
ABOUT TO MAKE A DECISION
THAT COULD CHANGE HIS LIFE--
A $1-MILLION DECISION.
I AM GONNA HAVE TO SAY
NO, THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANY PRICE?
YES.
WHAT'S THE PRICE?
MAKE IT A NATIONAL,
RECOGNIZED BRAND.
THERE YOU GO AGAIN. WHY DO YOU
WANT TO GO BACK TO THE BUSINESS?
MAY I PLEASE--
MAY I PLEASE FINISH?
BECAUSE I'M GONNA ANSWER
THE QUESTION,
BUT IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT THE MONEY.
I KNOW IT IS,
I'M NOT QUESTIONING THAT,
BUT IF YOU TOLD ME...
"I'LL GIVE YOU $30 MILLION,
BUT I'M GONNA PUT IT ON A SHELF
AND NEVER PRODUCE IT"...
WHAT YOU JUST SAID
MAKES ABSOLUTELY NO SENSE.
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE GONNA
SELL IT TO CAR COMPANIES.
WHY WOULD WE PUT IT
ON A SHELF?
I MEAN,
THAT JUST MAKES NO SENSE.
WHY WOULD YOU SAY THAT?
THAT'S CRAZY.
HE'S NOT A CORPORATION
TRYING TO TAKE YOUR PRODUCT
TO HIDE IT.
HE JUST WANTS TO MAKE MONEY,
SO THE MORE HE GIVES YOU,
THE MORE
HE'S GONNA WORK HARDER
TO MAKE SURE
THAT PRODUCT HITS THE MARKET.
LOOK, WHAT DO YOU THINK,
WE--WE WANT KIDS TO...
I DIDN'T MEAN
TO SUGGEST THAT.
I APOLOGIZE IF THAT'S
HOW IT WAS PERCEIVED.
THINK ABOUT IT. YOU'RE--
YOU'RE A BUSINESS GUY.
NO, YOU DON'T
HAVE TO APOLOGIZE.
YOU'RE A BUSINESS GUY.
YOU STARTED FROM A GOOD PLACE.
MM-HMM.
BUT YOU'RE
UNBELIEVABLY STUBBORN,
AND I THINK EVERYBODY HERE,
ALL THE SHARKS,
SEE THE VERY OBVIOUS WAY TO
MAKE MONEY AT THIS EXCEPT YOU.
AND EVERY TIME
WE THROW IT TO YOU,
YOU ACKNOWLEDGE IT,
BUT THEN YOU WANT TO GO OFF
AND RUN AND BUILD A BUSINESS.
I DON'T WANT TO BUILD
A BUSINESS.
I WANT TO TAKE THE PATH
OF LEAST RESISTANCE.
AND AGAIN, IT'S FLATTERING,
BUT NO, THANK YOU.
ROBERT, WE'RE DONE HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME.
♪♪
GREAT IDEA. WRONG GUY.
(Daymond) I'M--I'M SHOCKED
THAT HE TURNED DOWN THAT MONEY.
TOO BAD. LOST OPPORTUNITY.
THAT--THAT WAS
REALLY A GREAT PRODUCT.
(Barbara) MM-HMM.
IT WAS.
LIFEBELT IS
TREMENDOUSLY MORE IMPORTANT
IN THE ABILITY TO SAVE LIVES
THAN JUST A STACK OF MONEY
ON A--ON A TABLE.
THAT'S JUST NOT ENOUGH.
♪♪
NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS SUSAN KNAPP,
WHO BELIEVES SHE HAS
A DELECTABLE OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE SHARKS.
HI. MY NAME IS SUSAN KNAPP,
AND I AM THE CREATOR OF
A PERFECT PEAR FROM NAPA VALLEY.
I'M RAISING $500,000
FOR A 15% EQUITY STAKE
IN MY COMPANY.
OW!
(laughs) I TURNED
MY PASSIONATE HOBBY
OF MAKING MY SIGNATURE PRODUCT--
CINNAMON PEAR JELLY--
INTO A BUSINESS.
IT'S EVOLVED INTO A LINE
OF EXTRAORDINARY,
AWARD-WINNING
GOURMET FOOD PRODUCTS.
BUT DO YOU HAVE SALES?
WE'VE GROWN TO OVER $700,000
IN SALES.
WELL, WELL, WELL, WELL.
SO WHAT'S THE NET PROFIT?
AT THE END OF 2009,
WE EXPECT OUR NET PROFIT
TO BE 2.43%.
THAT'S ABOUT $15,000.
AT THE END OF, UH, 2010,
WE EXPECT OUR NET PROFIT
TO BE 10.5%.
(man) THANK YOU.
YOU'RE QUITE WELCOME.
SUSAN, IT'S FANTASTIC.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MMM. THAT'S GOOD.
MMM.
HOW MANY TOTAL STORES
ARE YOU ACTUALLY IN?
ABOUT 650.
SO WHAT DO YOU NEED
THE MONEY FOR?
WE NEED THE MONEY
TO HELP US WITH PRODUCTION.
I CURRENTLY HAVE OVER $100,000
WORTH OF ORDERS
THAT OUR CUSTOMERS
ARE EAGERLY WAITING FOR.
YOU CAN'T GET FINANCING
FROM A BANK OR SOMEBODY ELSE?
IT'S PRETTY DIFFICULT
RIGHT NOW.
EVEN A LOT OF
THE ANGEL INVESTORS
THAT ARE USUALLY AVAILABLE
IN THIS MARKET
HAVE BEEN
PRETTY DIFFICULT TO REACH.
THAT'S THE REAL PROBLEM
WITH WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN AMERICA TODAY
IS PEOPLE CAN'T GET CREDIT.
RIGHT, RIGHT.
DESERVING PEOPLE WITH
REAL BUSINESSES AND REAL ORDERS
CAN'T GET CREDIT.
MY CONCERN IS,
IS THAT YOU'RE NOT MAKING,
REALLY, MUCH PROFIT.
2% PROFIT ON $700,000--
THAT'S PROJECTED FOR THIS YEAR.
THAT'S A $15,000 PROFIT.
DON'T YOU THINK
WHAT YOU'RE ASKING
AND VALUING YOUR COMPANY FOR
IS TOO HIGH?
I PERSONALLY HAVE OVER $800,000
INVESTED IN THIS.
SUSAN, DON'T CARE ABOUT
THE PAST. DOESN'T MATTER.
OKAY,
EVERYBODY LOVES YOUR STUFF.
YOUR PACKAGING'S FANTASTIC.
YOU PRESENT VERY, VERY WELL.
PUT THAT ASIDE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE MONEY.
WE HAVE TO TAKE THE EMOTION
OUT OF IT AND MAKE IT REAL.
HOW ABOUT THIS DEAL?
500K...
AND YOU GIVE UP 70%
OF YOUR COMPANY.
ARE YOU ASKING ME
IF I WOULD ACCEPT THAT?
YES.
NO, THANK YOU.
OKAY, I HAVE $500,000...
FOR 51%.
51%?
51% TO ME.
I CONTROL THE COMPANY.
I'D GO 50%.
HALF A MILLION FOR 50%.
I'D GO IN ON THAT DEAL.
I THINK 50 IS FAIR,
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY,
YOU NEED THE MONEY,
WE GOTTA HAVE
SOME LEVEL OF CONTROL.
SO I'M IN WITH KEVIN
ON THAT DEAL.
DO WE HAVE A DEAL?
WELL, LET'S SEE--
SUSAN, LET'S BE CLEAR.
KEVIN AND I ARE OFFERING YOU
$500,000
FOR 50% OF THE COMPANY.
WHY DEAL WITH TWO GUYS WHEN YOU
COULD JUST DEAL WITH ONE
FOR 51%?
I WOULDN'T THROW OUT THE 70%
THAT LEAVES YOU WITH 30,
'CAUSE YOU GET TO WORK
WITH MR. WONDERFUL. THAT'S ME.
(laughs)
SUSAN, WE HAVE--
YOU HAVE AN OFFER.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO?
(exhales deeply)
YOU WANT TO GO IN THE DARK
AND THINK ABOUT IT?
FOR JUST A SECOND?
(Daymond) YOU WANT TO
STEP OUT ONE SECOND?
YEAH, GO AHEAD. PHONE
YOUR HUSBAND IF YOU HAVE TO.
DOES HE OWN
ANY OF THE BUSINESS?
NO.
(Barbara laughs)
(Harrington) HE JUST PUT
ALL THE MONEY IN.
OOH, THAT'S MEAN.
I LIKE HER EVEN MORE NOW.
FIRST OF ALL,
WHAT IS THIS 50% STUFF?
WE CAN GET 70% HERE.
EASILY. WE CAN GET 80%.
SHE SAID NO.
SHE SAID NO TO YOUR 70%.
(Harrington)
SHE TURNED YOU DOWN.
YEAH, BUT, YOU KNOW,
I HAVE 51.
YOU GUYS ARE TAKING MY DEAL,
ALMOST, FOR 1 POINT.
NO, BUT YOU GUYS, YOU UNDERCUT
ME BY GOING DOWN TO 50--
AND THEY UNDERCUT ME.
YEAH, THEY UNDERCUT HIM.
IT'S ALL FAIR. COME ON.
SHE WASN'T GONNA--
SHE'S NOT GONNA TAKE THAT.
(O'Leary) ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GET HER BACK.
SUSAN, YOU WANT TO COME BACK.
♪♪
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO?
SUSAN HAS TWO OFFERS
ON THE TABLE,
BOTH ASKING FOR A BIGGER CHUNK
OF HER COMPANY.
I LOVE THE FACT THAT
YOU'VE GOT $700,000 IN SALES,
YOU'VE GOT $100,000 IN ORDERS
WAITING TO BE FULFILLED.
I LOVE THAT, OKAY?
MY OFFER
WITH ROBERT AS MY PARTNER--
WE'LL EACH--
TOGETHER PUT UP $500,000
FOR 50% OF THE COMPANY.
MY OFFER IS...
I WILL GIVE YOU $500,000
FOR 51%.
THAT GIVES ME
CONTROLLING INTEREST,
BUT YOU ONLY HAVE TO DEAL WITH
ONE PERSON INSTEAD OF TWO.
(laughs)
YOU'RE ALL WONDERFUL.
NOW HERE'S WHAT I WOULD LIKE
TO PROPOSE TO YOU TWO GENTLEMEN
OR TO YOU.
WOULD YOU CONSIDER 49/51 SO I
MAINTAIN 51% OF THE COMPANY?
CAN'T DO THAT.
I DON'T WANT TO SPEAK
FOR KEVIN HARRINGTON,
BUT I CAN'T DO THAT.
NO.
AND I'LL TELL YOU WHY
I CAN'T DO THAT.
OKAY.
IN A SMALL BUSINESS,
THE DECISIONS YOU MAKE
CAN REALLY INFLUENCE
WHICH WAY WE'RE GONNA GO.
AND I JUST NEED TO BE INVOLVED.
BUT ALONG WITH KEVIN HARRINGTON,
I'M WILLING TO GO WITH YOU
'CAUSE I LIKE YOU.
SO I'M WILLING
TO SHARE RESPONSIBILITY,
BUT I'M NOT WILLING TO GIVE YOU
THAT RESPONSIBILITY.
OKAY.
I-I HAVE TO CONTROL MY MONEY.
YOU'VE SPOKEN FOR ME
VERY WELL. THANK YOU, ROBERT.
(Daymond)
YOU HAVE NOT GIVEN ME AN ANSWER.
CAN I HAVE CONTROLLING STAKE
OF YOUR COMPANY FOR 51%?
(blows air)
DO YOU KNOW, I HATE TO SAY IT?
BUT, UM...
BUT NO.
AND--AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THEN I'M OUT.
ARE YOU SAYING NO TO DAYMOND
OR ARE YOU SAYING--
I'M SAYING NO TO DAYMOND.
AND YOU TWO GENTLEMEN,
I'M, UM...
(O'Leary) SUSAN,
THINK ABOUT THIS.
YOU MAKE NO MONEY.
I WILL--OH, GOSH.
I-I WILL SAY YES TO.
YES.
(Barbara) HEY.
GOOD CHOICE.
AHA. AHA.
SHE'S GONNA SAY NO,
HUH, DAYMOND?
YOU TOOK ME FOR 1%.
SHE'S GONNA SAY NO, HUH?
SHE'S GONNA REGRET IT.
AH. SUSAN, YOU MADE
THE RIGHT DECISION.
WELL, AND HE LOVES
THE PRODUCT ALREADY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
OUTSTANDING.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MATCH.
(Daymond) THAT IS A--
THAT IS A GOOD DEAL.
THAT IS A GREAT LADY.
GREAT LADY.
(Robert) THAT IS
A GOOD LADY.
AH! I SHOULDA GOT IN
ON YOUR DEAL.
IT FEELS A LITTLE BIT SCARY
TO GIVE UP 50% OF MY COMPANY.
BUT KNOWING THAT MY INTENT
IS TO HAVE THIS BE
A $20-MILLION COMPANY
OVER THE NEXT FIVE YEARS,
WHAT'S 50%?
♪♪
NEXT INTO THE SHARK TANK
IS MARY ELLEN SIMONSEN,
WHO BELIEVES HER PRODUCT HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO MAKE MILLIONS.
HELLO. MY NAME
IS MARY ELLEN SIMONSEN.
I HAVE CREATED A PRODUCT THAT
WILL KEEP YOUR STICKY NOTES
IN PLACE AND ORGANIZED
WHILE WORKING AT YOUR COMPUTER.
I AM HERE TO ASK FOR
$100,000 IN-INVESTMENT
FOR 20% EQUITY IN MY COMPANY.
I CREATED THIS PRODUCT
BECAUSE I WAS TIRED
OF LOSING STICKY NOTES
AND HAVING TO REPOSITION THEM
ALL DAY LONG.
THIS EXAMPLE HERE
IS AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT
WE'RE ALL USED TO SEEING.
THERE'S BEEN NO CHANGE IN IT.
THERE'S BEEN NO SOLUTION TO IT
UNTIL TODAY.
YOU SIMPLY ATTACH IT
TO YOUR LAPTOP OR YOUR DESKTOP,
AND YOU PUT
ALL YOUR NOTES HERE.
YOU CAN ALSO ATTACH IT
TO THIS SIDE.
MARY ELLEN, YOU'VE CREATED
A STICKY PAD FOR STICKY PADS.
I CREATED AN ARM
FOR STICKY PADS.
THAT'S WORTH
HALF A MILLION DOLLARS?
YES.
PLEASE TELL ME WHY.
ALL YOU--
ALL YOU SIMPLY DO IS--
IS SWING THE SLEEVE IN
WHEN YOU'RE READY TO GO.
AND AS YOU CAN SEE,
NONE OF 'EM FALL OFF.
OH, I SEE WHY IT'S WORTH
HALF A MILLION DOLLARS.
THANK YOU!
IT FOLDS INTO THE COMPUTER.
(sharks laugh)
OF COURSE THAT MAKES SENSE
TO ME NOW.
YOU'VE SOLD HOW MANY?
I HAVE SOLD NONE.
EXCELLENT. EXCELLENT.
I THINK WE SHOULD KEEP THIS
A SECRET.
IT'S SO VALUABLE THAT NOBODY
SHOULD KNOW ABOUT THIS.
COME ON.
WHO'S GONNA BUY THIS
FROM YOU?
THIS YEAR ALONE,
56 MILLION LAPTOPS WILL BE SOLD
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND EVERY ONE OF THEM
DOESN'T NEED YOUR STICK ARM.
THIS YEAR ALONE,
OVER 400 MILLION LAPTOPS
WILL BE SOLD WORLDWIDE.
HOW MUCH IS IT WORTH?
WHAT WOULD I PAY FOR THAT?
UH, $9.50.
STOP THE MADNESS.
ARE YOU OUT OF YOUR MIND?
(Daymond) $9.50 FOR ONE?
YES.
ARE YOU CRAZY?
WHO WOULD GIVE YOU
10 BUCKS FOR THAT?
A LOT OF PE--
A LOT OF PEOPLE.
(Robert) HOW DO YOU KNOW THAT?
HOW DO YOU KNOW THAT?
I'VE--I'VE DONE SURVEYS.
THERE'S SO MANY
BAD THINGS ABOUT THIS,
LET ME COUNT THE WAYS.
I'M OUT.
MARY, CONVINCE ME WHY THIS ISN'T
THE WORST IDEA I'VE EVER SEEN.
THIS YEAR ALONE, THERE'LL BE
56 MILLION LAPTOPS--
OKAY, YOU GOTTA
STOP THAT RIGHT AWAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT? I CAN'T TELL YOU
HOW MANY PEOPLE COME TO ME
AND SAY "IF I CAN GET 1% OF 1%
OF THE BILLION"...
YOU--YOU... ZERO FROM ZERO
IS STILL ZERO.
SO FORGET THAT. LET THAT GO.
GIVE ME ANOTHER ONE.
GIVE ME ANOTHER REASON
WHY THIS IS GREAT.
THIS IS SOLVING A PROBLEM
THAT EVERYBODY HAS
WHO USES STICKY NOTES--
I DON'T HAVE THAT PROBLEM.
WHO USES STICKY NOTES
WHILE WORKING AT THEIR LAPTOP.
HAVE YOU SHOWN THIS TO ANYBODY
THAT SAID,
"I LIKE THIS
AND WE'LL SELL IT FOR YOU"?
I HAVE NOT
BECAUSE I HAVE NOT
SECURED A PATENT YET.
DON'T WASTE YOUR TIME
OR THE MONEY ON THE PATENT.
I THINK NO SALES,
A USELESS IDEA. I'M TOTALLY OUT.
IF YOU
WALKED IN HERE TODAY
WITH SOME KIND OF INTEREST
IN THIS PRODUCT,
UH, I THINK YOU MAY BE GETTING
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT REACTION
FROM US RIGHT NOW.
SO I'M OUT.
I DON'T THINK YOUR PRODUCT
IS WORTH WHAT YOU'RE ASKING,
BUT I DO THINK YOU HAVE
A PRODUCT THERE.
AND I THINK FOR $10 A POP
ON A QVC-TYPE STATION--
WHAT PLANET
DID YOU COME FROM?
YEAH. NO, LET ME TELL YOU.
I THINK YOU COULD SELL IT.
I LOVE THIS LADY. YOU'RE SOLID
ON YOUR FEET, ALL RIGHT?
I JUST DON'T THINK YOU'RE GONNA
MAKE A BUSINESS OF THIS.
YOU KNOW, BARBARA--
SO FROM ME, I'M OUT,
BUT NOT BECAUSE OF YOU.
I THINK YOU NEED A NEW PRODUCT,
BUT I'M OUT.
BARBARA, YOU GOTTA,
YOU GOTTA STOP THAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THAT'S WHY SHE'S HERE.
SHE'S HERE WITH A HORRIBLE IDEA
BECAUSE SOMEBODY IN HER FAMILY
OR HER FRIENDS SAID THAT, TOO.
I'M NOT HER FRIEND.
"YOU'RE REALLY NICE,"
AND ENCOURAGED YOU.
HAVE YOU SPENT ANY OF YOUR OWN
MONEY DOING THIS?
I'VE SPENT ABOUT $1,000.
THAT'S THE GOOD NEWS. YOU SHOULD
STOP. FIND SOMETHING ELSE.
MOVE ON. I'M OUT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
(Harrington)
GOOD LUCK, MARY ELLEN.
♪♪
NEXT INTO THE SHARK TANK
IS MARC FURIGAY,
WHO BELIEVES HIS BUSINESS
IS AN INVESTMENT
IN AMERICA'S FUTURE.
♪♪
MY NAME'S MARC FURIGAY.
I LIVE IN CHICAGO, ILLINOIS.
AND MY PRODUCT IS GONNA
REVOLUTIONIZE THE WAY
THINGS ARE TAUGHT IN SCHOOL.
I'M A HIGH SCHOOL
ENGLISH TEACHER.
I'VE BEEN TEACHING
FOR ABOUT EIGHT YEARS.
(students laugh)
I'VE ALWAYS LOVED READING,
AND I LOVE KIDS AS WELL,
SO AS A TEACHER, I WANTED
TO SHARE THIS ENTHUSIASM
WITH THE KIDS.
NOW TODAY WE'RE GONNA DO AN EVEN
DEEPER CHARACTER ANALYSIS
OF LADY MACBETH.
IT GOT PRETTY FRUSTRATING
WHEN A LOT OF KIDS
HAD A HARD TIME GETTING INTO
WHAT THEY WERE READING,
UH, PARTICULARLY SHAKESPEARE.
THEY JUST TUNED OUT.
SO I FIGURED THERE HAD TO BE
A BETTER WAY TO GET THEM
INTO THE LITERATURE.
SO I CREATED SOMETHING
NEW, INNOVATIVE,
AND IT COMPLETELY CHANGED
THE CLASS DYNAMIC.
WHO IS THE STRONGER,
HARDER CHARACTER,
MACBETH OR LADY MACBETH?
IN ALL MY YEARS OF TEACHING,
I'VE NEVER COME ACROSS
ANYTHING THAT WORKS
NEARLY AS WELL
AS THE PRODUCT I'VE CREATED.
IT WAS THE CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT TURNED HIM INTO
THE RUTHLESS KING THAT HE WAS.
THEIR MARRIAGE WAS GOOD.
YOU THINK LADY MACBETH
STARTED OFF GOOD?
SHE STARTED OFF GOOD.
IT WAS ALL ABOUT HER GREED.
THE TITLE OF THE PLAY IS
"MACBETH" BECAUSE HE'S BETTER.
(laughing)
WHAT I WANT TO SHOW THE SHARKS
IS THAT THIS IS NOT JUST
AN AMAZINGLY EFFECTIVE
TEACHING TOOL,
BUT IT IS AN AMAZING
BUSINESS OPPORTUNITY.
♪♪
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS MARC FURIGAY.
I'M THE CREATOR AND FOUNDER
OF CLASSROOM JAMS--
AN EDUCATIONAL RECORD LABEL
AND PUBLISHING HOUSE
SET TO LAUNCH.
I'M HERE SEEKING $250,000
FOR A 10% STAKE IN THE COMPANY.
AS A TEACHER
IN CHICAGO PUBLIC SCHOOLS,
I SAW A VERY HUGE NEED
FOR TEACHING TOOLS
THAT ACTUALLY WORKED.
NO MATTER WHAT RESOURCES
WE HAD, KIDS KEPT FAILING,
AND TEACHERS KEPT BURNING OUT.
ONE DAY, UH, WHEN I WAS
REALLY STRUGGLING
TO GET KIDS INTERESTED
IN SHAKESPEARE,
A STUDENT OF MINE
SUMMED UP THE PROBLEM PERFECTLY.
SHE SAID, "MR. FURIGAY,
WHY CAN'T YOU GIVE US SOMETHING
WE CAN RELATE TO?"
I TOOK THOSE WORDS TO HEART.
THE NEXT DAY,
I CAME IN WITH A SONG.
I--I'LL PLAY YOU
JUST THE FIRST VERSE.
IT'S CALLED
"THE JUBILEE OF JULIET, PART 1."
(plays guitar notes)
♪ THE JUBILEE OF JULIET ♪
♪ HASN'T EVEN STARTED YET ♪
♪ BUT GET THE PARTY ON TONIGHT ♪
♪ AND YO
THERE'S GONNA BE A FIGHT ♪
♪ CAN YOU FEEL
THE FEELING YET ♪
♪ OF FIERY TYBALT CAPULET? ♪
♪ SEE TYBALT HATED MONTAGUES ♪
♪ THE FAMILY
AND THE FEELING TOO ♪
WELL, THE KIDS LOVED IT.
THAT WAS REALLY GOOD.
(Daymond) VERY GOOD,
VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU.
THAT WAS REALLY GOOD.
OKAY. HOW DO WE MAKE MONEY?
WE MAKE MONEY BY SELLING
OUR, UH, CLASS SETS
TO SCHOOLS NATIONWIDE.
MARC, DO YOU OWN A-A COPYRIGHT
TO THAT SONG? LIKE--
YES.
HAVE YOU WRITTEN
ALL THE SHAKESPEAREAN CLASSICS
MUSICALLY?
I WROTE AND PERFORMED
ALL THE SONGS ON THE ALBUM.
WOW. SO YOU'RE SELLING US
THE ENTIRE RECORD LABEL?
THAT'S PART OF THE BUSINESS?
YES, EXACTLY.
AND THE RIGHTS TO THE SONGS?
UM, I AM NOT SELLING
THE RIGHTS TO THE SONGS.
OOH.
I AM SELLING A STAKE
IN THE RECORD LABEL
AND THE PUBLISHING HOUSE.
BUT WHY NOT THE SONG?
THE SONG IS SOMETHING THAT
I WOULD LIKE TO KEEP CONTROL OF.
YOU ARE A NASTY MAN.
SCHOOL IS YOUR CUSTOMER,
CORRECT?
CORRECT.
WHAT'S THE COST TO THE SCHOOL?
A CLASS SET COSTS, UH, $499,
AND IT INCLUDES 30 CDs
AND THE TEACHER'S GUIDE.
WHY--WHY SHAKESPEARE?
ANY OTHER PROGRAMS, LIKE WHY--
YOU'RE SEEING AHEAD.
PRECISELY.
THE REASON I CHOSE SHAKESPEARE
WAS BECAUSE, UH,
HE IS THE MOST WIDELY TAUGHT
WRITER IN THE ENGLISH LANGUAGE.
HE'S PROBABLY ONE OF THE HARDEST
TO UNDERSTAND, TOO.
PRECISELY, UM,
AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT KIDS REALLY
STRUGGLE WITH THE MOST.
SO ANY OTHER ONES? ARE YOU
DOING ANY OTHER--
UH, THE NEXT THREE, UH,
WE'RE PLANNING ON
WILL TARGET DIFFERENT,
UH, DIFFERENT SUBJECTS--
HISTORY, SCIENCE--
MARC, I'D LIKE YOU
TO DO ME A FAVOR.
I'D LIKE YOU TO WALK OUTDOORS
FOR A MINUTE. LEAVE US ALONE.
OKAY.
(O'Leary) I-I LIKE THIS DEAL.
THIS IS WHY I WANTED
TO CALL A SESSION TOGETHER.
LET'S NOT
BID AGAINST EACH OTHER.
FIRST OF ALL, THERE'S NO WAY ON
EARTH HE'S WALKING OUT OF HERE
WITHOUT THE PUBLISHING RIGHTS
IN THE DEAL.
$250,000 FOR 100%
OF THE BUSINESS,
AND HE GETS A 5% ROYALTY
AFTER WE RECOUP OUR DOUGH.
I LOVE IT, BUT I MEAN,
I'D LOVE TO BE TALLER, TOO.
I JUST DON'T THINK
HE'S GONNA DO IT.
I'M NOT GIVING HIM ANY DOUGH
UNLESS I HAVE TOTAL CONTROL
AND I OWN ALL THE RIGHTS.
THAT'S IT.
MEAN GUY.
BUT A ROYALTY STREAM FOR HIM
CAN BE WORTH MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OVER THE--OVER TIME,
SO THIS IS STILL A VERY--
A VERY GOOD OFFER.
CALL HIM BACK IN.
MARC, COME ON DOWN.
(O'Leary) YOU KNOW,
I'VE GOTTA TELL YOU SOMETHING.
YOU'RE A VERY LUCKY GUY TODAY,
THAT WE MET.
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU RICH,
I THINK.
BUT YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO
REALLY THINK THIS THROUGH.
WE FORM A NEW COMPANY.
WE OWN IT.
WE FUND IT WITH $250,000.
IT'S A PUBLISHING COMPANY
FOR YOU.
JUST LIKE A GREAT ARTIST,
YOU'RE GONNA MAKE A ROYALTY--
IN PERPETUITY,
FOR THE REST OF YOUR LIFE, 5%.
THE FIVE SHARKS
HAVE OFFERED MARC
UM...
FASCINATING.
I--IT'S A--IT'S A GREAT--
IT'S GREAT TO IMAGINE THAT THE--
YOU WOULD BE WILLING TO DO THAT.
UM, BUT...
I'D LIKE
TO BUILD THIS COMPANY--
STOP RIGHT THERE.
DO YOU WANT TO BE RICH OR NOT?
I DO WANT TO BE RICH.
WELL, LET'S GET FOCUSED
ON THAT, BUDDY.
BUT DO YOU WANT TO HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THE EVERYDAY ASPECTS
OF SALES, DISTRIBUTION,
MANUFACTURING?
OR DO YOU WANT TO BE ABLE
TO DO EXACTLY WHAT YOU DO,
AN ARTIST AND A TEACHER?
THIS--THE LATTER SOUNDS IDEAL,
ALTHOUGH, I MUST SAY,
SINCE I STARTED TO THINK ABOUT,
UH, STARTING A BUSINESS,
THE MARKETING, THE SALES,
UH, THE NETWORKING
IS ALSO VERY EXCITING.
IT WON'T BE AFTER A WHILE.
HOW MANY TIMES IN YOUR LIFE
HAVE FIVE PEOPLE SAID,
"LET ME GIVE YOU $250,000
TO START A COMPANY,
"OF WHICH YOU, FOR THE REST
OF THE DAYS YOUR ALIVE,
"MAKE A ROYALTY,
REGARDLESS OF HOW HARD
IT IS FOR US TO SELL IT"?
I GUESS WHAT I'M CONCERNED
WITH IS, 5% FEELS QUITE SMALL.
IN PERPETUITY? FOREVER?
THE MODEL OF ROYALTIES
IS A GREAT DEAL FOR YOU.
YES.
WHY AREN'T YOU JUMPING
ALL OVER THIS?
I SENSE THAT YOU'RE CONCERNED.
WELL, THERE IS THE--THE QUESTION
OF THE EQUITY STAKE.
I LIKE THE IDEA OF MAINTAINING
EQUITY IN SOMETHING--
BUT THAT'S NOT THE OFFER
ON THE TABLE, MY FRIEND.
THE OFFER ON THE TABLE RIGHT NOW
IS TO SET UP A NEW COMPANY...
MM-HMM.
THAT THE SHARKS OWN,
AND YOU GET,
WHICH IS A GREAT DEAL,
A PERCENTAGE OF THOSE SALES
FOR SIMPLY CREATING MATERIAL.
UM, I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
A COUNTEROFFER.
WE'RE ALL EARS.
I WOULD LIKE TO BE, UH,
SIX PLAYERS
AS CO-OWNERS OF THE COMPANY.
IT'S UN-AMERICAN,
WHAT YOU'RE ASKING.
YOU DON'T WANT TO TAKE
ANY RISK.
YOU WANT US TO SPEND
ALL OF OUR DOLLARS,
GIVE YOU FREE EQUITY
AND GET A ROYALTY.
DO YOU SEE THE PROBLEM
WITH THAT?
I-I DON'T SEE IT AS FREE--
AND LOOK AT HOW WE'RE STRUGGLING
TO MAKE IT WORK FOR YOU.
I-I APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH.
UM, I DON'T SEE IT
AS FREE EQUITY.
DON'T TRY TO BE A SHARK.
YOU--YOU EITHER GET EQUITY
OR YOU DO A ROYALTY DEAL.
I HEAR YOU SAYING
"I LOVE MY BUSINESS."
YOU HAVE A PASSION FOR IT.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $250,000.
I'LL GIVE IT TO YOU ON MY OWN.
♪♪
BUT I WANT 100% OF THE BUSINESS,
AND I'LL GIVE YOU AN OPTION
TO WORK BACK TO 49%.
ROBERT HAS MADE MARC
HIS OWN OFFER--
$250,000 FOR 100%
OF THE COMPANY
WITH THE OPTION
TO BUY BACK 49% OF IT
WITH PROFITS
MADE FROM THE BUSINESS.
UH, UH--
EXCUSE ME. YOUR DEAL
HAS NO ROYALTY IN IT.
NO ROYALTY.
SO YOU GET NOTHING.
MAY--MAY I TAKE NOTES?
(chuckles)
NO, SEE, IT'S VERY SIMPLE.
YOU DON'T NEED TO TAKE NOTES.
ROBERT JUST OFFERED YOU NOTHING
AND TOLD YOU TO POUND SAND
FOR A LONG TIME.
NO, I DIDN'T.
I DIDN'T DO THAT.
I THINK YOU DID.
I GAVE HIM A SHOT
AT THE BRASS RING.
YOU'RE GIVING HIM NOTHING.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO?
ALL FIVE SHARKS MADE MARC
AN OFFER TOGETHER,
BUT ROBERT
HAD A CHANGE OF HEART
AND MADE HIM AN OFFER
ON HIS OWN.
I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
A-A PER--A COUNTEROFFER.
(O'Leary) JUST BEFORE
YOU MAKE THAT MOVE,
MAYBE YOUR OTHER DEAL
IS GONNA EVAPORATE.
JUST LIKE A DOG
WITH A BONE IN HIS MOUTH
LOOKING AT A REFLECTION
IN THE RIVER,
YOU BETTER MAKE SURE,
BEFORE YOU OPEN YOUR MOUTH,
THE BONE DOESN'T DROP OUT HERE.
HE'S NOT GONNA DO THE DEAL.
HE'S NOT STUPID.
I DIDN'T HEAR THAT YET.
I MEAN, I WENT ALONG WITH IT
BECAUSE I THOUGHT, SURE,
IF HE DOES THE DEAL,
I'M HAPPY TO GO ALONG WITH IT,
BUT HE'S NOT GONNA DO THE DEAL.
ARE YOU GONNA LET THAT BONE
DROP OUT OF YOUR MOUTH?
BECAUSE MAYBE I'LL EVAPORATE
ON THAT.
OBVIOUSLY I'M GETTING CUT OUT
IN ROBERT'S SCENARIO,
AND THAT REALLY MAKES ME
QUITE UNHAPPY, MARC.
I'M LESS INTERESTED
IN, UM, JUST ONE.
I LIKE THE IDEA OF HAVING
FIVE RESOURCES.
NOW I'M OFFENDED.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH ME?
NOTHING IS WRONG
WITH YOU, ROBERT.
I-I REALLY LIKE THE IDEA OF
HAVING FIVE BUSINESS PARTNERS.
YOU KNOW WHAT, MARC?
FORGET THAT.
THAT'S JUST
WAY TOO COMPLICATED FOR ME.
I'LL GIVE YOU $250,000.
UM, I GET 51%, YOU GET 49%.
YOU GOTTA BE KIDDING.
WHAT HAPPENED THERE?
ROBERT HAS JUST SWEETENED
HIS OFFER
BY GIVING MARC THE 49% STAKE
IN HIS COMPANY
WITHOUT HAVING TO BUY IT BACK.
YOU'VE JUST SEEN GREED.
THAT'S WHAT YOU'VE SEEN, BUD.
YOU'VE SEEN A GUY
SCREW HIS PARTNERS.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
YEAH, BUT YOU--
AND I WON'T FORGET THIS,
ROBERT.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
DO YOU NEED A HUG, KEVIN?
YOU'RE NOT GONNA GET
ANY HELP FROM ME ON THIS DEAL.
(laughs) AY-YI-YI.
MARC, YOU HAVE TO START
MAKING A DECISION. WHICH ONE?
THAT--THAT WAS WHY
I WANTED TO TAKE NOTES.
YOU KNOW, THE BIG RISK IS YOU'RE
GONNA WALK OUT THE DOOR
SINGING THE BLUES IN "E."
YOU KNOW WHAT
THE BIG RISK IS?
I'M GONNA SAY I'M OUT
IN LESS THAN A MINUTE.
WE'VE BEEN HERE
FOR WAY TOO LONG.
IT'S GETTING MORE COMP--
IT'S WAY TOO MANY DEALS.
YEAH, IF STUFF IS NOT SIMPLE,
I'M ABOUT TO BE OUT.
AND I'M A SIMPLE GUY.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE MONEY.
UM, I REALLY LIKE
THE IDEA--
I-I REALLY LIKE THE IDEA OF
HAVING FIVE BUSINESS PARTNERS.
MARC REJECTED ROBERT'S OFFER
IN HOPES OF SECURING A DEAL
WITH ALL FIVE SHARKS TOGETHER.
CAN YOU, UH, REDESCRIBE
WHAT YOUR NEW COMPANY
WOULD LOOK LIKE--
OKAY, ONE MORE TIME
WITH FEELING.
YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE TO WRITE
THIS DOWN. IT'S THIS SIMPLE.
WE FUND THE NEW CO.
WITH $250,000,
YOU START MAKING 5% FOR THE REST
OF YOUR LIFE ON SALES,
REGARDLESS OF WHAT
OUR COSTS ARE.
HE HAS NO EQUITY.
HAS NO EQUITY.
IF YOU WANT--
OKAY--
AFTER WE'VE RECOVERED
THE $250,000 INVESTMENT,
WE LET HIM USE
HIS ROYALTY STREAM
TO ACQUIRE THE EQUAL EQUITY
AMONGST OURSELVES.
THAT MAKES SENSE TO ME. THAT'S
REAL DOLLARS FOR REAL EQUITY,
'CAUSE BY THEN--
IS THAT SOMETHING
YOU'D CONSIDER, MARC?
UM... THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING
I WOULD CONSIDER,
BUT I WOULD LIKE THE ROYALTIES
TO BE, UM, MUCH HIGHER
TO BE ABLE TO, UH,
ATTAIN EQUITY MUCH MORE QUICKLY.
CAN WE DO 8 1/2%?
NO.
OKAY, SO IT WOULD--
MARC, ARE YOU SURE
YOU'RE JUST AN ENGLISH TEACHER?
OR REALLY, DID YOU DO AN M.B.A.
AND YOU JUST DIDN'T TELL US?
(Barbara laughs)
UH, I AM SURE I AM--
HE LOOKS LIKE
AN ENGLISH TEACHER.
I'M AN ENGLISH TEACH--
UH, AN ENGLISH TEACHER.
'CAUSE YOU'RE TRYING TO DRIVE
A DEAL THAT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO GET,
IN THIS ROOM
OR ANYWHERE ELSE ON EARTH.
DO WE HAVE A DEAL,
YES OR NO?
♪♪
LET'S GO INTO BUSINESS.
WHOO! ALL RIGHT.
MARC, CONGRATULATIONS.
GREAT IDEA, MAN.
THANK YOU.
LIKE A REALLY, REALLY
GREAT IDEA.
YOU'RE A VERY WISE MAN.
THAT WAS VERY GOOD, MARC.
(Harrington) GOOD JOB.
THANK YOU.
OKAY, THAT WAS A GOOD DEAL.
I TAKE IT BACK.
THAT WAS A GOOD DEAL.
HE SHOULD'VE NEVER GONE FOR THAT
DEAL, BUT I'M HAPPY TO DO IT.
THAT WAS GOOD.
I FEEL INVIGORATED.
NEXT WEEK ON "SHARK TANK"...
WHAT'S YOUR COST OF
MANUFACTURING THESE THINGS?
I DON'T KNOW. YOU KNOW--
EVERY TIME YOU'D SAY
"I DON'T KNOW,
I'D HIT YOU WITH
AN ELECTRIC CATTLE PROD.
I MEAN, YOU GOTTA KNOW
THIS STUFF.
I-I-I REALLY CAN'T BELIEVE
THAT YOU ARE NOT APPRECIATING
WHAT I'VE DONE.
YOU SEE ANY PROBLEM
WITH THAT?
I-I SEE NO PROBLEM WITH IT.
I THINK--
I SEE GREED. I SEE GREED.
WANTING TO MAKE MONEY
IS WHAT THIS IS ALL ABOUT.
YOU HAVE NO BUSINESS
BEING HERE.
SOME OF THIS
COMES FROM BELIEF.
YOU'RE YOUR OWN WORST ENEMY.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
SAVE YOUR BREATH.
♪♪